> HAY NDAY EVERNE.COEREN CHAIONY
TO GET THE PARTY STARTED.
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT IS "THE SQUAD RIDE" LIVE IN
THE BLEACHER REPORT APP
PRESENTED BY DRAFT KINGS.
MY NAME IS CONNOR ROGERS
ALONGSIDE GREG IVORY.
WELCOME TO LOUISIANA, RIGHT?
SHOUT-OUT TO LOUISIANA JOINING
THE FUN, GETTING IN ON THE FUN.
LOUISIANA OFFICIALLY HAS SPORTS
BETTING LEGALIZED.
SO GOOD FOR THEM.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
YOU ARE A LITTLE LATE.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THIS ALL
YEAR.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THIS A LONG
TIME.
BUT HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE.
ALL RIGHT, GREG.
IT'S CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIP
WEEKEND.
WHAT ARE WE HOOKING THE PEOPLE
UP WITH TODAY.
>> CONNOR, WHAT AREN'T WE
HOOKING UP THE PEOPLE WITH
TODAY?
WE GOT A LOT.
WE GOT CUSTOMIZED BOOTS FROM OUR
FRIENDS AT DRAFT KINGS.
OF COURSE WE'RE GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
OF COURSE WE'RE GIVING AWAY MORE
JERSEYS.
BUT, CONNOR, WE'RE ALSO GIVING
AWAY A PAIR OF AIR POD PROS.
AND I DON'T HAVE THOSE YET, AND
I KIND OF WANT SOME, SO I HAVE
TO HIT UP THE PRODUCER AND SEE
IF I COULD FEN NIS MY WAY INTO
THEM.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
GO AHEAD.
>> BUT, CONNOR, BUT, BUT, BUT
LET ME HOP IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
I GOT TO HOP IN THE COMMENTS.
>> PLEASE.
>> BECAUSE -- BECAUSE IT'S TIME
TO GIVE OUT A HOODIE.
SO I'M IN THE COMMENTS, AND I
SEE -- I SEE 49ERS SHOUT-OUT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
I ALSO HAVE WEEKEND LOCKS.
SAYS CJ ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN I
LIKE THAT.
HE WAS ON MY FANTASY TEAM.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MOVING ON, IT IS TIME TO DO WHAT
WE DO BEST.
THAT'S RIGHT.
BEFORE GREG GIVES OUT MORE
HOODIES, YOU HEARD IT.
WE GOT AIR PODS AGAIN.
HOW ARE WE DOING THIS GRAND
PRIZE.
STICK AROUND FOR THAT.
IT IS TIME TO DO WHAT WE DO
BEST.
LOCKS.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TWO IS GETTING
IN THE END ZONE ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL SUNDAY.
WE ASK YOU ON SOCIAL.
WE ASK YOU IN THE APP AND HERE
ARE THE TOP PICKS OF THE WEEK.
BYRON PRINGLE AT THE TOP OF THE
BOARD.
I THINK THIS IS BYRON PRINGLE'S
DEBUT ON THE BOARD, AND WHAT A
TIME TO MAKE AN ENTRANCE.
ODELL BECKHAM JR. RIGHT NEXT TO
HIM THERE.
HE'S HAD A RESURGENCE WITH THE
RAMS.
Ja'MARR CHASE, YOUR FUTURE
OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
DEEBO SAMUEL, JOE MIXON, TRAVIS
HILL, TWO VERY FAMILIAR FACES OF
CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIP WEEKEND.
AND THEN COOPER KUPP WHO JUST
CONTINUES TO GET IT DONE FOR
THOSE RAMS IN THE BIGGEST
MOMENTS, ESPECIALLY IN THE END
ZONE.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, WE HAVE
FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO SHOW
YOU.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL RIGHT NOW.
LAST ONE STANDING TAKES HOME THE
SQUAD RIDE TITLE, TAKES HOME THE
JERSEY.
GREG WILL BOOST THE ODDS.
AND THEN WE'RE ALL GOING TO BET
ON THAT PLAYER TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN IN ONE OF THESE TWO
GAMES.
LET'S WASTE NO TIME AND GET
RIGHT INTO IT.
THE FIRST PICK IS FROM THE 511
PODCAST, MAKING THEIR SQUAD RIDE
DEBUT.
LET'S SEE THE PICK.
>> YO, GUYS.
WHO DO YOU LIKE FOR ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWNS THIS WEEKEND?
>> JUST A COUPLE OF BROS LOOKING
FOR LOCKS AT THE FRAT HOUSE.
PRINGLES AS IN BYRON PRINGLE.
THE 511 BROS GOING WITH BIG PLUS
MONEY HERE, GREG, AT PLUS 190.
SO WE GOT ONE ON THE BOARD.
BUT WE NEED A CHALLENGER.
WHO BETTER THAN FRANKIE'S PICKS
TO ENTER THE ARENA RIGHT NOW?
GO AHEAD, FRANKIE.
>> WE GOT PATRICK MAHOMES,
Ja'MARR CHASE, DEEBO SAMUEL.
WE'RE GOING TO HIT ALL THREE
SHOTS.
WHOEVER IS CLOSEST TO THE PIN,
WE'RE HAMMERING IT.
OH.
>> WE COME UP HERE FIRST ONE.
DEEBO, NEVER HAD A CHANCE.
NEVER HAD A CHANCE.
GOT A CLEAR WINNER RIGHT HERE.
WHO IS IT?
PATRICK MAHOMES PLUS 225.
HAMMER IT.
IT'S A LOCK.
WE'RE PRAYING FOR PARLAYS OUT
HERE.
LET'S GO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THE GOLF LEGEND FRANKIE GIVING
US HIS LOCK IN PATRICK MAHOMES
PLUS 225.
WE GOT TEAMMATES FOR ROUND ONE
ON THE BOARD HERE, GREG.
LET THEM KNOW WHAT WE NEED.
>> WE NEED EVERYBODY, YES, YOU,
TO GET INTO THE COMMENTS AND LET
US KNOW IF YOU ARE RIDING WITH
MY MAN BYRON PRINGLE OR IF YOU
ARE ROCKING WITH PATRICK MAHOMES
SITTING AT PLUS 225.
CONNOR, I'LL JUMP IN HERE.
BYRON PRINGLE PLUS 190.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT IT.
I FEEL REAL EH.
I KNOW MY GUY GOT INTO THE END
ZONE IN THE LAST TWO GAMES.
I JUST -- THERE IS A LOT OF
WEAPONS PATRICK MAHOMES HAS.
HE'S ALSO A WEAPON.
I WILL TALK ABOUT HIM IN A
MINUTE.
BYRON PRINGLE PLUS 190.
IF YOU GOT THE MONEY TO SPRINKLE
IT ON IT, THEN DO IT.
BUT I'M STAYING AWAY.
I THINK I WANT TO LEAN PATRICK
MA HOMES IN THIS MATCHUP RIGHT
HERE, CONNOR.
MY GUY HAS BEEN LOOKING GOOD.
HE'S BEEN RUNNING THE BALL AS OF
LATE.
IT IS THE PLAYOFFS.
WE KNOW -- WE KNOW IT'S WHEN THE
LIGHTS ARE ON AND YOU GOT TO
MAKE THOSE BIG TIME PLAYS.
EVERYBODY IS MAKING ADJUSTMENTS.
MY GUY IS BROING OUT.
CAN'T FIND NOBODY.
HE'S RUNNING, LOOKING REAL
SPRUNKY OUT THERE, CONNOR.
SO PLUS 225.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO
HERE ON "THE SQUAD RIDE."
I'M ROCKING WITH PAT HERE,
CONNOR.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> YEAH.
I'M GOING WITH MAHOMES AS WELL.
I THINK IN THE PLAYOFFS YOU ARE
SEEING SO MANY DIFFERENT PLAYS
BREAK DOWN AND MAHOMES LOOKS AS
ATHLETIC AS HE EVER HAS BEEN.
WHEN HE TAKES A LOT OF BIG HITS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE SEASON,
SOMETIMES HE COMES INTO THE
PLAYOFFS HOBBLED.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM IN THE SUPER
BOWL HOBBLED.
RIGHT NOW HE LOOKS TO BE AT HIS
BEST.
HE LOOKS TO BE PICKING UP YARDS
WHEN THEY'RE THERE OR EXTENDING
PLAYS.
SO I LIKE THE NUMBER A LITTLE
BETTER HERE, GREG.
PLUS 225 FOR MAHOMES.
TWO GUYS THAT I THINK ARE ALMOST
EVEN IN MY EYES.
PRINGLE HAS DONE IT.
THE PRINGLE BROS, THAT'S A GOOD
PICK.
IT IS AN OFF THE BOARD PICK.
IT IS NOT, HEY, TRAVIS KELCE IS
GOING TO SCORE.
I LIKE THE CREATIVITY.
BUT I JUST LIKE MAHOMES' NUMBER
A LITTLE BIT BETTER HERE.
BUT WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS
GOING?
ARE THEY ROLLING WITH THE
PRINGLE BROS OR THE GOLF LEGEND
IN FRANKIE?
>> CONNOR, FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
DON'T KNOW, THIS RIGHT HERE IS
THE HANDY DANDY iPAD.
THIS IS WHERE I READ THE TAKES
RIGHT HERE.
I GOT AK47 BIG BLUE SAYS DO
BOTH.
IT IS BIG MONEY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
ALSO -- ALSO, HOLD ON, MY GUY
SPACE ALIEN SAYS CHASE, PRINGLE
AND MAHOMES ARE ALL LOCKS TO
SCORE TODAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
CONNOR, I'M GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION HERE.
I SEE A LOT OF PRINGLE IN THE
COMMENTS.
A LOT OF PRINGLE.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO ROCK WITH
IT.
I GOT -- I JUST LOCK IT.
HERE IT IS.
SALTY STASH.
BRADEN SAYS BYRON PRINGLE TODAY.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, SALTY
STASH.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, IT APPEARS THE FIRST
ROUND OF BYRON PRINGLE PULLING
OFF THE UPSET OF PATRICK MAHOMES
IN THE FIRST ROUND.
SO BYRON PRINGLE IS MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT ROUND.
>> YEAH.
IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT THE PEOPLE
FADE BOTH YOU AND I IN THE SAME
PICK, GREG.
BUT WE WENT WITH MAHOMES.
THEY'RE GOING WITH PRINGLE.
IT'S OKAY.
NO HARD FEELINGS.
WE'RE MOVING ON WITH BYRON
PRINGLE TO ROUND TWO.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED A WORTHY
CHALLENGER, IT SEEMS, TO TAKE
BYRON PRINGLE OFF THE BOARD.
SO WE GOT LA ROSA 23 COMING IN.
AND, GREG, I THINK YOU ARE GOING
TO LIKE THIS ONE.
>> WE WILL ROLL SOME DICE.
AS YOU CAN SEE, WE GOT OUR
PLAYERS LISTED OUT WITH ALL THE
NUMBERS ON THE BOARD, AND WE'RE
GOING TO LET THE DICE DO THE
TALKING.
HERE WE GO.
DICE IS OUT.
WE GOT A FOUR.
DEEBO SAMUEL ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORE.
>> MY MAN SOUNDED LIKE AN EXTRA
FROM "GOODFELLAS" OR "THE
CASINO."
DEEBO SAMUEL MINUS 110.
A BIG CHANGE IN ODDS, BUT A BIG
CHANGE IN PLAYER.
THIS MAN IS THE NINERS OFFENSE.
GREG, I THINK THIS ONE GETS YOU
A LITTLE BIT MORE EXCITED.
THIS IS ONE I THINK YOU HAVE A
LITTLE BIT EASIER OF A TIME
SIGNING UP FOR.
AM I RIGHT?
>> YES, SIR.
YES, SIR.
MY MAN DEEBO SAMUEL, HE IS THE
NINERS OFFENSE, THE 49ERS
OFFENSE.
HE PLAYS RUNNING BACK.
HE PLAYS WIDE RECEIVER.
PUT HIM AT KICK RETURN.
PUT HIM AT PUNT RETURN.
THOSE ARE ALL WAYS MY GUY CAN
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
BUT THE 49ERS FOCUS ON GIVING
HIM THE BALL.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, WE GOT
BYRON PRINGLE, WHO IS PLUS
MONEY, PLUS 190.
WE GOT DEEBO SAMUEL WHO HAS BEEN
GETTING IN THE END ZONE IT SEEMS
LIKE EVERY GAME.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHERE I'M GOING TO
LEAN.
TALK TO ME.
LET ME KNOW.
ARE YOU LEANING PRINGLE, OR ARE
YOU ROCKING WITH DEEBO?
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING,
BROTHER?
>> I LIKE DEEBO BETTER.
I THINK IT MAKES IT EASIER
RATHER THAN THE MINUS MONEY.
I THINK THAT'S THE BIG MONEY FOR
ME.
WITH DEEB, IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT THE TARGETS
AND HE'S AVERAGING ONLY FOUR IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
BUT WHEN YOU GET TEN CARRIES A
GAME ON TOP OF THAT, GREG, IT
COMPLETELY CHANGES THE DYNAMIC
OF YOUR POTENTIAL TO SCORE.
I LOOK AT DEEBO AND THINK HE'S A
THREAT.
I LIKE THE MATCHUP AGAINST THE
RAMS EVEN THOUGH HE MIGHT SEE
JALEN RAMSEY.
YOU DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT AS
MUCH IN A KYLE SHANAHAN OFFENSE.
YOU CAN MOVE HIM AWAY FROM
CORNERS THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY
GOING TO BE TRAILING YOU THE
WHOLE GAME.
SO BYRON PRINGLE AT PLUS 190, IT
SEEMS GOOD, RIGHT?
HE SCORED THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS
AND THE FACT THEY CAN RUN UP THE
SCORE AT TIMES AND GET THE
OFFENSE GOING.
BUT THIS IS THE PLAYOFFS, GREG.
WHEN THE LIGHTS ARE ON AND THE
HEAT IS TURNED UP, YOU GO TO THE
GUYS THAT GOT YOU THERE.
FOR US, FOR ANYONE THAT'S PLAYED
FANTASY FOOTBALL OR HAS BET ON
THE NINERS, THAT'S BEEN DEEBO
SAMUEL WAY MORE THAN BYRON
PRINGLE.
SO I'M ROLLING WITH DEEBO.
>> CONNOR, YOU ARE PREACHING TO
THE PEOPLE TODAY BECAUSE THE WAY
YOU JUST BROKE THAT DOWN, MY
BROTHER, THAT DESERVES A GRAMMY
OR WHATEVER YOU WANT TO OH THAT
DESERVES AN AWARD, MAN, BECAUSE
THAT WAS SPOT-ON.
BUT I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW SEEING WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
I GOT CHLEO.
DEEBO SAMUEL FOR THE WIN, GUYS.
SILENCING THE CROWD OUT THERE IN
SEATTLE.
HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS CAN SEE IT
RIGHT THERE.
MOVING ON, I GOT ANOTHER --
UH-OH, I GOT THE SAME EXACT GIF.
THERE IT IS.
OH, THERE.
RIGHT THERE.
THERE IT IS.
SO YOU ARE ALSO WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
ONE MORE.
ONE MORE, CONNOR.
GOT ANOTHER GIF.
DEEBO FROM FRIDAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
CONNOR, IT IS APPARENT.
DEEBO SAMUEL IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> SO DEEBO GOING ON TO THE
FINAL ROUND.
BUT WE GOT ONE MORE CHALLENGER.
AND YOU KNOW WE GOT TO JUST
BRING IN A NO NONSENSE STONE
COLD LOCK LEGEND FOR ROUND
NUMBER THREE.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING TO W.
TRAMMELL, BECAUSE IT'S
CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIP WEEKEND.
LET'S SEE THE PICK.
>> WHAT'S UP, BR NATION?
>> IT'S POP FOR A LOCK.
Ja'MARR CHASE, LOCK IT IN.
>> THE FUTURE OFFENSIVE ROOKIE
OF THE YEAR, Ja'MARR CHASE.
PLUS MONEY, GREG.
PLUS MONEY.
>> YEAH.
>> I LIKE BOTH OF THESE GUYS TO
SCORE THIS WEEKEND.
SO THIS IS HOW I'M GOING TO FIND
MY WAY, HOW I'M GOING TO FIND A
CHOICE.
WHICH GAME IS THERE GOING TO BE
MORE POINTS.
YOU LOOK AT THE OVER/UNDER LINE.
BENGALS/CHIEFS A SET OF 54.
NINERS/RAMS AT 45.
A NINE-POINT DIFFERENCE.
THAT IS MONUMENTAL.
SO FOR ME, I THINK DEEBO SHOULD
BE THE OFFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR.
I JUST SUBMITTED MY VOTE FOR HIM
TO BE OFFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR.
THIS WEEK I LIKE Ja'MARR CHASE
TO SCORE JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
BECAUSE OF THE PACE OF THE GAME,
BECAUSE OF THE CONTEXT OF THE
GAME.
GREG, I KNOW YOU ARE ON YOUR
NINERS AND YOU ARE NOT A TRAITOR
IF YOU GO AGAINST DEEBO THIS
YEAR.
>> CONNOR, I WILL KEEP THIS
SHORT AND SWEET.
I LOVE BOTH PICKS HERE.
WE KNOW WHAT Ja'MARR CHASE IS TO
THAT BENGALS OFFENSE.
HE WILL BE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR
FOR A REASON.
NOW, HE HASN'T BEEN SCORING AS
OF LATE, BUT HE'S STILL BEEN
BALLING AS FAR AS RECEPTIONS AND
YARDS CATEGORY PUTTING UP AN
ABUNDANCE.
WE KNOW.
I KNOW THEY'RE IN THOSE BENGALS
PRACTICES AND THOSE BENGALS
COACHES ARE TALKING.
AND THEY KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO
GET Ja'MARR CHASE INSIDE OF THE
END ZONE.
THEY KNOW THAT.
WE KNOW THAT.
VEGAS KNOWS THAT.
SO I KIND OF LEAN TOWARDS
Ja'MARR CHASE, EVEN THOUGH I
THINK DEEBO SAMUEL WILL GET IN
THE END ZONE AS WELL.
THE ONLY REASON IS BECAUSE OF
PLUS 100.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO
HERE ON THE SQUAD RIDE.
WE'RE GOING TO BOOST IT.
I'M JUST PLAYING THE ODDS HERE.
I LIKE BOTH PICKS, BUT I LEAN
Ja'MARR CHASE SIMPLY BECAUSE
IT'S A BETTER NUMBER.
>> IT IS A BETTER NUMBER.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
THIS ONE, TO ME, IS -- I MEAN,
THERE IS A REASON THEY'RE ALMOST
EVEN ANYWAY.
SO YOU CAN'T REALLY GO GROWN
HERE.
YOU KIND OF WANT TO PARLAY THEM
TOGETHER, GET A LITTLE CRAZY.
BUT WE'LL SAVE THAT FOR SOME
MORE FUN WE HAVE DOWN THE ROAD.
ALL RIGHT, GREG.
LET'S GET THIS ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE.
YOU KNOW WHO WE RELY ON TO DO
THAT, THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING RIGHT NOW.
>> THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING,
BRO.
I HAVE A NINER FAN, WHO IS A
NINER FAN, ALLEN MENDOZA SAYS
GIVE IT TO MY BOY W. TRAMMELL.
AIN'T GOING TO LIE.
I'M GOING TO WITH BOTH.
HE SAID -- HE'S THE DART LEGEND.
HE SAID Ja'MARR CHASE.
NINER FANS SAID HE'S GOING TO
ROCK WITH Ja'MARR CHASE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU WALK AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I GOT ELIA WHO SAYS SEE YA TO
THE HATERS.
PUT A GIF IN THE COMMENTS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
SHANNON SAYS Ja'MARR CHASE IS A
LOCK.
I'M JUST GOING TO STOP RIGHT
THERE.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED, YOU
ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES BUT CONNOR IT IS
APPARENT.
THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
LOOK AT THE COMMENTS.
THEY'RE SPEAKING RIGHT NOW AS I
SPEAK.
Ja'MARR CHASE.
IT APPEARS THAT HE IS THE SQUAD
RIDE WINNER THIS WEEK.
SO LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC
BECAUSE I WANT TO SHOW YOU GUYS
SOME MAGIC THAT WE CAN DO HERE
ONLY ON "THE SQUAD RIDE" WITH
OUR FRIENDS OVER AT DRAFT KINGS.
YOU GUYS SEE THIS.
IT SAYS PLUS 100.
POOF.
THERE IT IS.
BOOSTED IT UP TO PLUS 125.
SHOUT-OUT TO OUR PEOPLE AT DRAFT
KINGS AND SHOUT-TOUT TO
EVERYBODY THAT'S GOING TO RIDE
WITH US.
LET'S ALL GET RICH RIGHT WITH
OUR MAN Ja'MARR CHASE.
>> Ja'MARR CHASE, UP TO PLUS
125.
AND SHOUT-OUT TO T. TRAMMELL,
THIS WEEK'S SQUAD RIDER BRINGING
IT.
BUT WE'RE NOT DONE, GREG.
WE GOT TO TALK THROUGH THESE
MATCHUPS.
WE GOT TWO GAMES ON THE SLATE.
THE BEST OF THE BEST FROM THE
AFC.
NFC.
WE WILL GIVE OUR FAVORITE TOP
BETS FROM EACH MATCHUP.
BEFORE WE DO THAT, MAKE SURE TO
GET ON DRAFT KINGS FIRST BECAUSE
FOR FIRST-TIME CUSTOMERS, YOU
CAN PLACE A MONEY LINE BET OF $5
OR MORE DURING THE POSTSEASON.
IF YOUR BET WINS, YOU WILL
RECEIVE $280 IN FREE BETS IN
ADDITION TO YOUR CASH WINNINGS.
GREG, THAT SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD,
RIGHT?
>> CONNOR, THAT SOUNDS AWESOME.
CONNOR AND I WILL GO THROUGH
THESE GAMES.
AND WE'RE GIVING YOU OUR
FAVORITE MAJOR MARKET PICKS.
SO I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL US WHAT
YOU THINK -- TELL US WHAT YOU
THINK.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES, AND I'M
ALSO GIVING AWAY A JERSEY,
CONNOR.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT, MAN.
LET'S GET TO THIS FIRST MATCHUP,
MAN.
>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
THE BENGALS GOING TO KANSAS CITY
TO TAKE ON THE CHIEFS.
A BIG SPREAD FOR A CONFERENCE
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
THE BENGALS ARE UNDERDOGS BY A
FULL TOUCHDOWN.
GREG, WHEN THIS OPENED AT 7:00,
RIGHT AWAY ON TUESDAY MORNING,
MONDAY MORNING, I JUMPED ALL
OVER THIS FOR THE BENGALS TO
COVER BECAUSE I THOUGHT THIS
LINE WOULD MOVE TO FOUR AND A
HALF, FIVE AND A HALF.
IT DID NOT.
IT STAYED RIGHT THERE.
AND THEY'RE GIVING YOU WORSE
ODDS IF YOU ROLL WITH THE
CHIEFS.
SO THEY'RE TELLING YOU WHAT THEY
REALLY THINK OF THAT ONE.
I LIKE THE BENGALS TO COVER.
I THINK THE TOUCHDOWN IS A LOT
IN ANY CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME.
IF I WAS LOOKING TO GET AWAY
FROM THE SPREAD, IT IS STILL A
HIGH NUMBER.
I STILL LIKE IT.
MAYBE I PARLAY IT WITH A SPREAD
DOWN TO 50 LIKE I USUALLY DO
WITH POINT TOTALS AND PARLAYS.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN THE JOE BURROW
HYPE?
>> CONNOR, I'M GOING TO ACTUALLY
STAY AWAY FROM THE GAME AS FAR
AS PICKING THE SIDE.
AND I'M GOING TO LOOK AT THAT
POINT TOTAL.
AND MY HEART, MY HEART, MAN, MY
HEART WANTS THE OVER.
I WANT TO SEE A SHOOT-OUT.
54 POINTS, THAT'S A LOT.
I WANT TO SEE, SIMILAR TO LAST
WEEK, LAST WEEK PATRICK MAHOMES
TAKING ON JOSH ALLEN AND THE
BILLS, THAT SHOOT-OUT, HOW CRAZY
THAT WAS.
MY MIND IS TELLING ME TAKE THE
UNDER.
SO I'M GOING TO FADE MY HEART.
I WILL FADE MYSELF AND I WILL
TAKE THE UNDER HERE, CONNOR.
I WILL TAKE THE UNDER.
IT'S THE PLAYOFFS.
I KNOW THESE TWO DEFENSES HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING, BUT IT IS THE
PLAYOFFS.
IT IS THE AFC CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND I THINK THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO MAKE SOME TYPE OF
ADJUSTMENTS.
AND IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO BE
THE SHOOT-OUT THAT WE THINK THAT
IT WILL BE, CONNOR.
SO I WILL ROCK WITH THE UNDER ON
THIS ONE.
>> I LIKE IT.
I MEAN, YOU SAID IT EARLIER WHEN
WE WERE TALKING FADE FOR
YOURSELF.
WHAT YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE IT SEEMS SO
OBVIOUS.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A REASON.
54 IS A BIG POINT TOTAL.
WE WILL SEE THAT DIFFERENCE WHEN
WE GO THROUGH THE NEXT GAME.
GREG, WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS
GOING?
WHAT BOLD BETS OR NORMAL BETS DO
THEY LIKE HERE?
WHAT ARE THEY ON SO FAR?
>> LET ME SEE.
I'VE GOT A -- I'VE GOT SPACE
ALIENS BACK.
BENGALS AND 49ERS ARE PLAYING
EACH OTHER IN THE SUPER BOWL.
SHOUT-OUT TO THAT.
LOVE THE TAKE.
ALSO GOT JACK BOY.
JACKBOY37 SAYS PARLAY JOE MIXON
OVER RECEIVING YARDS, OVER
PASSING.
THIS IS A LOCK.
HE PUT A WHOLE PARLAY DOWN.
WE GOT CHIEFS.
HE SAID TAKE THE RAMS MINUS 3.5
AND THE OVER IN THE
CHIEFS/BENGALS GAME.
GET ME A JERSEY.
I CAN'T GET YOU A JERSEY RIGHT
NOW, BUT I'M GIVING YOU A
HOODIE.
SHOUT-OUT TO JACKBOY37.
WEEKEND LOCK SAYS WHO DA?
JAY P. ALSO ROCKING WITH YOU,
CONNOR, AND THE BENGALS.
SO THE COMMENTS ARE UP AND DOWN,
BACK AND FORTH, BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE YOU GOT SOME PEOPLE ROCKING
WITH YOU, CONNOR.
>> PEOPLE ARE, SITED ABOUT THE
BENGALS.
GREG, IT IS ALWAYS EASIER TO
ROOT FOR THE NEW KID ON THE
BLOCK.
BE EXCITED TO MAYBE SEE HIM IN
THE SUPER BOWL.
MAHOMES HAS BEEN THERE.
NOW HE WILL BE THE VILLAIN.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO NOT LIKE
PATRICK MAHOMES.
ALL RIGHT.
MOVING ON, THESE TEAMS ARE NOT
NEW CONTENDERS BECAUSE YOUR
NINERS, IT IS NOT THAT LONG AGO
THEY WERE IN A SUPER BOWL.
IT IS NOT THAT LONG AGO THAT
SEAN McVAY HAS BEEN THERE, BUT
THESE TEAMS WANT TO GET OVER THE
HUMP AND WIN THAT TITLE.
LOOK AT THIS WIN, GREG.
3.5 POINTS.
THE NINERS ARE ON THE ROAD.
HOME TEAM USUALLY GETS THREE.
VEGAS IS TELLING YOU THINK THEY
ESPECIALLY WITH THE HISTORY
BETWEEN THESE TWO, THIS IS AN
EVEN MATCHUP BETWEEN THE NINERS
AND THE RAMS.
AND WITH THAT THOUGHT PROCESS,
GREG, SIMPLE FOR ME, SIMPLE PICK
HERE.
TAKE THE POINTS AT THE NINERS.
TAKE THE THREE AND A HALF
POINTS.
THEY ARE BASICALLY SAYING WE
DARE YOU.
WE THINK THE RAMS WIN BY MORE
THAN A FIELD GOAL.
I DON'T.
IF I WAS A LITTLE MORE BOLDER, I
WOULD GO NINERS MONEY LINE.
BUT I LIKE THE SAFENESS OF
NINERS 3.5.
SO THAT'S WHERE I'M ROLLING.
WHERE ARE YOU AT?
I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO BE
THERE?
I KNOW YOU'RE FIRED UP FOR THIS
GAME.
>> YES, SIR.
>> I JUST WANT TO KNOW, ARE YOU
GOING NINERS POINTS OR NINERS
MONEY LINE HERE?
>> CONNOR, WE GOT A SEGMENT --
WE GOT A SEGMENT LATER IN THE
SHOW CALLED BONUS BETS.
YOU KNOW, WE DO IT EVERY WEEK.
I GOT A LITTLE TREAT FOR YOU
GUYS THEN.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE ARE GOING TO
PLAY IT SAFE HERE, CONNOR.
THE NINERS BEAT THE RAMS SIX
TIMES IN A ROW.
THE NINERS BEAT THE RAMS TWO
TIMES THIS YEAR.
I THINK, IF ANYTHING, CONNOR,
THIS WILL BE A GOOD GAME.
IF THE RAMS PULL IT OUT, THEY
PULL IT BY A FIELD GOAL.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE A
REALLY, REALLY CLOSE GIG.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, THREE AND
A HALF, THEY'RE GIVING US THE
HOOK.
I JUST SAID IT.
IF THE RAMS WIN, I THINK IT WILL
BE BY A FIELD GOAL.
TAKE THE THREE AND A HALF RIGHT
THERE.
THE 49ERS, I MEAN, THEY BEAT THE
RAMS TEAM TWICE.
THEY BEAT THE RAMS TEAM TWICE.
MY MAN CONNOR SAID IT BEST.
VEGAS THINKS IT'S THE PICK EM,
SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE TEAM I
HAVE SEEN BEAT THIS TEAM TWICE.
I KNOW IT IS HARD TO BEAT A TEAM
THREE TIMES, BUT IT'S THE
PLAYOFFS, BABY.
IT'S THE PLAYOFFS.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE NINERS
PLUS THREE AND A HALF ON THIS
ONE.
>> IT'S THE PLAYOFFS.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER AT WHAT POINT
THEY KNOW SEAN McVAY.
THEY WERE TOGETHER IN WASHINGTON
FOR A LONG TIME, AND NOW YOU CAN
KIND OF SEE THE HISTORY HERE
WHERE IT FEELS LIKE McVAY IN
THESE MATCHUPS, GREG, IS PLAYING
WITH MORE.
HE'S GOT MORE WEAPONS.
HE'S GOT THE BETTER QUARTERBACK.
HE'S GOT PLENTY ON DEFENSE.
AND SOMEHOW KYLE JUST GETS IT
DONE WITH THESE GAME PLANS.
SO AT SOME POINT, YEAH, IT'S
HARD TO BEAT A TEAM THREE TIMES.
IT IS HARD TO BEAT A TEAM THAT
MANY TIMES IN GENERAL, BUT YOU
HAVE TO BELIEVE IN SHANAHAN ADD
SOME POINT.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS GOING
RIGHT NOW?
WE'RE SO NINERS HEAVY AND WE
HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE THE
PLAYOFFS.
I DIDN'T THINK THEY WOULD BEAT
THE PACKERS, AND THEY DID THAT.
NOW WE'RE BACK TO PICKING THEM
HERE.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS AT THIS
WEEK FOR THE NFC CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME?
>> I SEE A LOT OF NINERS FANS
AND NINERS BETTERS IN THE
COMMENTS.
YOU SEE RIGHT THERE NICK, PLUS
3.5.
PUNCH THE TICKET.
LET'S SEE.
I GOT BEN THE GOAT RIGHT THERE
AT SF PLUS THREE AND A HALF.
EASY, HOT TAKE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
WE GOT ALSO, LET ME SEE, WE GOT
DONTE HERE.
RAMS MONEY LINE ALL DAY.
SAN FRAN POINTS, HE'S TRYING TO
MEDAL RIGHT THERE.
I GOT ONE MORE.
RAMS AND IT WON'T BE CLOSE.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY.
THAT WAS TEVON216 SAYS RAMS AND
IT WON'T BE CLOSE.
SHOUT-TOUT TO EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
LET'S GET RICH, CONNOR.
>> COOL.
>> LET'S TRY TO GET RICH.
WE HAVE MORE EXCITING SEGMENTS
COMING UP.
>> SHOUT-OUT TO ALL THE
COMMENTERS. DON'T FORGET TO GET
ON DRAFT KINGS.
BET $5, WIN $280 IN THOSE BONUS
BETS WHEN YOU LOCK DOWN.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOCK DOWN
A MONEY LINE BET THIS SEASON.
IT'S TOO EASY.
DANGEROUSLY EASY.
WE ARE LOOKING AT PLAYER PROPS.
THIS WEEK WE ARE LOOKING AT
QUARTERBACK PROPS.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE FOCUSSING ON
RIGHT NOW.
SO THAT BEING SAID, GREG, WHAT
ARE WE STARTING WITH RIGHT NOW?
WHICH ONE OF THESE QUARTERBACKS
ARE WE STARTING WITH?
>> WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO
IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET
US KNOW IF YOU ARE ROCKING WITH
THESE PROPS OR IF YOU ARE
LOCKING THEM IN OR IF YOU ARE
DROPPING THEM.
JUST LET US KNOW.
TYPE SOMETHING OUT.
FIRST UP, WE WILL GET IT STARTED
WITH YOUR BOY, LSU'S FINEST.
JOE BURROW IS SITTING AT
OVER/UNDER 291.5, CONNOR?
291.5.
JOE BURROW, TALK TO US, CONNOR.
YOU LIKE THAT OR YOU DON'T?
>> ONE I STAY AWAY FROM.
I'M DEFINITELY NOT GOING TO CALL
IT A LOCK, OKAY?
IF THIS GAME GOES THE WAY WE
WANT, HE HAS TO GET OVER THIS
MARK TO DUAL IT OUT WITH
MAHOMES.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THE PACE OF
THIS GAME.
WHAT IF KANSAS CITY GETS UP TWO
TOUCHDOWNS AND THEY JUST WANT TO
TRY TO RUN THE BALL AND THE PACE
OF THE GAME COMPLETELY CHANGES.
I THINK BURROW THROWS FOR TWO TO
THREE TOUCHDOWNS.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
THE YARDAGE TOTAL SCARES ME A
BIT.
291.5 IS A MONSTER NUMBER.
I KNOW HE'S HAD PHAM MOUTH
GAMES, BUT THIS IS NOT MY
FAVORITE PROP THAT WILL GO
THROUGH ON THIS LIST.
IS THIS TOO HIGH FOR YOU AS
WELL?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THIS ONE IS TOO HIGH FOR
ME AS WELL, CONNOR.
I JUST MENTIONED, I JUST
MENTIONED I WANT THE SHOOT-OUT.
BUT MY MIND IS JUST TELLING ME
NO.
SO I HAVE TO CONNECT THE DOTS
HERE, CONNOR.
YOU SAID SHOOT-OUT MY GUY JOE
BURROW IS GOING OVER.
NO SHOOT-OUT, HAS TO GO UP.
SO I'M GOING UNDER.
I JUST DON'T SEE MY GUY LIKE NOT
SAYING I CAN'T.
BUT I'M ROCKING WITH THE UNDER
AS WELL IN THIS PROP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SPEAKING OF BURROW, IF YOU ARE A
LOUISIANA BETTER JOINING US
TODAY, OUR FRIENDS OVER AT DRAFT
KINGS THEY ARE HOOKING YOU UP.
THEY HAVE A SWEET DEAL FOR YOU,
FOR YOU GETTING IN ON THE FUN
RIGHT HERE.
IN HONOR OF SPORTS BETTING
BECOMING LEGAL IN YOUR STATE,
DRAFT KINGS IS GIVING YOU ALL
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DOUBLE YOUR
MONEY.
THAT'S IT.
RIGHT THERE.
DOUBLE YOUR MONEY IF JOE BURROW
COMPLETES A PASS.
NOT A TOUCHDOWN, NOT A YARDAGE
TOTAL.
NOT A CERTAIN AMOUNT.
ALL HE HAS TO DO, GREG, IS
COMPLETE ONE PASS.
THE MAN HAS A 70% COMPLETION
PERCENTAGE.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO COMPLETE
THE PASS.
YOU CAN DOUBLE YOUR MONEY.
MAX WAGGER $25.
>> YEAH.
I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT MY MAN JOE
BURROW WILL GET AT LEAST ONE
PASS COMPLETED TODAY.
SO THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S A GOOD DEAL, CONNOR.
>> IT IS A GOOD WELCOME TO THE
PAR.
WE'RE NOT DONE WITH THESE PROPS
YET.
WE'RE LOOKING AT HIS OPPONENT
ACROSS THE WAY IN PATRICK
MAHOMES.
SEND OUT ANOTHER HIGH NUMBER.
293.5 YARDS.
NOW WE KNOW MAHOMES CAN DO THIS
ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
THAT SHOULD NOT SURPRISE YOU.
IT JUST COMES DOWN TO WHAT KIND
OF STYLE GAME ARE THE CHIEFS
GOING TO PLAY?
IS THIS GOING TO BE A SHOOT-OUT?
IF I HAD TO GO ONE WAY HERE,
GREG, I DON'T BET AGAINST
MAHOMES AND NUMBERS, ESPECIALLY
ANYTHING THAT DOESN'T START WITH
A THREE.
IF I HAVE TO GO WITH ANYTHING
HERE, I'M GOING TO ROLL WITH THE
OVER ON PATRICK MAHOMES' PASSING
TOTAL.
IN THE PLAYOFFS, HE BECOMES A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT ANIMAL.
>> EXACTLY.
I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU,
CONNOR.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PATRICK
MAHOMES HERE.
WE KNOW WHAT HE DOES.
LIKE HE'S BEEN IN THESE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP GAMES BEFORE, SO
HE'S VERY FAMILIAR.
AND I JUST CAN'T BET AGAINST THE
GUY.
I CANNOT BET AGAINST THE GUY.
293.
I DID SAY I WANT THE UNDER TO
HAPPEN IN THE GAME.
BUT THAT DON'T MEAN THAT THE
CHIEFS CAN RUN IT UP.
MAYBE THE BENGALS LAY AN EGG OR
A COUPLE EGGS.
SO I'M LEANING TOWARDS THE OVER
HERE.
MY MAN PAT MAHOMES TO PUT ON A
SHOW AGAINST THAT CINCINNATI
BENGALS DEFENSE.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH IT, CONNOR.
I'M ROCKING WITH YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GREG LIKES MAHOMES OVER YARDS.
TAKING THINGS OVER TO THE NFC,
THE NFC CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH MATT
STAFFORD.
OVER 282.5 YARDS.
GREG, I'M GOING TO GO UNDER ON
THIS ONE FOR STAFFORD.
HE'S HAD SOME BIG GAMES.
A HUGE ONE AGAINST TAMPA.
I THINK THE NINERS WILL PUT THE
CLAMPS A LITTLE ON THIS ONE
WHERE I THINK THE RAMS COME OUT
A LITTLE RUN HEAVY.
A LITTLE MORE RUN HEAVY THAN
WE'RE USED TO SEEING WITH THEM.
I DON'T THINK STAFFORD HAS A BAD
GAME.
I JUST LOOK AT IT AND GO 282.5
IS A LOT.
HE DOESN'T NEED TO DO THAT TO
WIN.
SO I DO NOT LIKE THIS NUMBER FOR
STAFFORD.
UNLIKE MAHOMES, I'M GOING TO GO
UNDER ON THIS ONE.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> CONNOR, I'M GOING TO GO UNDER
WITH YOU.
BUT HERE'S WHY.
LAST TIME THE 49ERS PLAYED THE
RAMS, MATTHEW STAFFORD GOT OFF
TO AN INCREDIBLE FIRST HALF
PERFOR
PERFORMANCE.
I'M PRETTY SURE YOU REMEMBER
YOUR BOY SEAN McVAY IN THE END
ZONE CELEBRATING WITH HIS OWN
TEAM.
YES, THE HEAD COACH WAS IN THE
END ZONE CELEBRATING WITH HIS
TEAM IN THE FIRST HALF OF THE
GAME.
CONNOR, THEY LOST THAT GAME.
YES, THEY DID LOSE THAT GAME.
BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WERE MADE AT
HALFTIME.
MY GUY MATTHEW STAFFORD DID NOT
LOOK THE SAME IN THE SECOND HALF
THAT HE LOOKED IN THE FIRST
HALF.
I THINK THOSE ADJUSTMENTS WILL
CONTINUE TODAY AS FAR AS IN THE
PASSING GAME WITH THE RAMS AND
THE 49ERS.
SO I DO THINK THE RAMS WILL COME
OUT AND LOOK TO RUN THE BALL,
GET PLAY ACTION GOING IN ORDER
TO OPEN UP THE PASS.
BUT WITH ALL OF THAT BEING SAID,
CONNOR, ALL THAT BEING SAID, MY
GUY'S OVER/UNDER IS 282.5.
I'M NOT PUTTING MONEY ON IT.
THE THIRD BEST RANKED DEFENSE IN
THE LEAGUE, I'M NOT PUTTING MY
MONEY ON IT.
I KNOW HE HAS COOPER KUPP AND
ODELL BECKHAM.
WILL HE HAVE THE TIME, CONNOR?
WILL HE HAVE THE TIME AGAINST
THE NINERS PASS RUSH?
SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE UNDER.
>> YEAH.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS A NINERS
DEFENSE THAT JUST HELD AARON
RODGERS TO 225 YARDS AND HE'S
PROBABLY GOING TO WIN THE MVP.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS.
IT WASN'T A BLIZZARD THE ENTIRE
GAME.
THEY WERE STILL TRYING TO THROW.
THE GUY HAD ALMOST 30 DROPBACK
ATTEMPTS.
SO I'M WITH YOU.
I THINK SHANAHAN EFFECT HE'S
GOING TO HAVE -- HE'S GOING TO
HAVE HIS DEFENSIVE STAFF SO
READY FOR WHAT SEAN McVAY WANTS
TO DO, IT IS A LOT TO ASK FOR
STAFFORD.
NOT A LOT TO ASK FROM OUR NEXT
QUARTERBACK.
JIMMY G. COMING IN OVER 50 YARDS
LOWER ON THE TOTAL HERE.
230.5 YARDS.
I WILL SHOCK PEOPLE HERE, GREG.
JIMMY HAS NOT THROWN FOR OVER IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
I'M GOING OVER HERE.
I THINK THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
CATCH AND RUN THROWS SCHEMED UP
FOR THIS ONE.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE A LOT ON
KITTLE TO DEEBO.
I DON'T THINK HE THROWS 300, 350
YARDS.
BUT I THINK HE GETS TO THE 240,
250 MARK IN THIS GAME.
I THINK JIMMY IS READY TO GO IN
THIS ONE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE MAHOMES OUT
THERE.
BUT I THINK THE OFFENSE HE'S
PLAYING IN WILL ALLOW HIM TO
THROW THE BALL MORE AND HIT THIS
MARKER.
I LIKE JIMMY G. OVER.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING IT.
>> I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU,
CONNOR.
DON'T BE AFRAID, BRO.
DON'T BE AFRAID.
BECAUSE, LOOK, THE LAST TIME WE
HIT THIS MARK, GUESS THE TEAM
THAT IT WAS AGAINST.
THESE LOS ANGELES RAMS.
SO DON'T BE AFRAID, BROTHER.
WE OFTEN SEE JIMMY NUMBERS ARE
LOW.
I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO SAY
THAT.
BUT LAST WEEK AND THE WEEK
BEFORE HIS NUMBERS WERE LOW
CONSIDERABLY FOR THROWING THE
BALL.
THERE IS CERTAIN TEAMS THAT KYLE
SHANAHAN I WOULD SAY HE HAS ON A
LEASH.
HE DOESN'T LET HIM FLOURISH.
HE DOESN'T LET HIM GO AND THROW
THE BALL.
BUT THE RAMS -- WHEN THE 49ERS
PLAY THE RAMS, IT IS A TEAM THAT
HE LETS JIMMY G. GO OUT THERE
AND THROW THE BALL.
SO I CAN SEE MY GUY JIMMY
DROPPING BACK TODAY AND JUST
SLINGING THE BALL AROUND.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
THE 49ERS WILL STAY WITH THE
RUN.
THAT'S THEIR IDENTITY.
THEY WILL STAY AND STICK TO THE
RUN.
BUT DON'T BE ALARMED IF YOU SEE
SOME PLAY ACTION, DEEP SHOTS.
IF YOU SEE SOME PLAY ACTION
BOOTLEGS BECAUSE KYLE SHANAHAN
LETS MY GUY JIMMY G. SLING THE
BALL AGAINST THESE RAMS.
SO I'M TAKING THE OVER.
>> I LIKE IT.
OVER FOR JIMMY G.
NOW WE GOT TO ASK.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS GOING?
BECAUSE GREG HAS GOT NOT JUST
HOODIES BUT AN NFL JERSEY OF
YOUR CHOICE TO GIVE AWAY HERE.
SO GET IN ON THE PROP ACTION,
EVERYBODY.
WHICH QUARTERBACK OVER/UNDER DO
YOU LIKE?
IS THERE ANOTHER PROP FOR THESE
GAMES?
GREG, WHERE ARE THEY GOING RIGHT
NOW?
>> THEY'RE ALL OVER THE PLACE IN
THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW, CONNOR.
YOU GUYS, YOU GUYS CAN SEE LIKE
LITERALLY THEY'RE JUMPING ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
I GOT -- WE'RE GETTING SPAMMED
BY SPACE ALIEN.
HE KEEPS ON PUTTING THE SAME
PICK.
49ERS WILL ROLL THE RAMS TODAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU TODAY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE -- ALSO HAVE RAIDER
909 SAYS JIMMY G. ON THE OVER.
YES WITH THE GIF.
HHJOHNSON SAYS OVER JIMMY G.
SO THEY'RE ROCKING WITH THE
GAROPPOLO OVER.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE ALL WALKING AWAY
WITH HOODIES.
CONNOR, WE MIGHT BE ON TO
SOMETHING WITH THAT JIMMY G.
OVER, BROTHER.
>> I'M SURPRISED PEOPLE LIKE IT.
I LIKE THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
FADING THE JIMMY G. PICK.
WE ARE -- WE ARE ALL IN.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING IT.
AND SPEAKING OF THOSE COMMENTS,
WE GOT A COUPLE TO LOOK THROUGH
FROM THIS WEEK.
BASICALLY, WE WANT TO KNOW YOUR
BEST BETS FOR CHAMPIONSHIP
SUNDAY.
WE WANT YOUR TAKES ON THEME
GAMES.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
GREG, WHAT IS THE FIRST ONE THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH HERE?
>> CONNOR, I'M HERE, BROTHER.
THIS IS THE COMMENT FROM THE
BOSS.
HE SAYS NINERS GROUND GAME AND
SUFFOCATING DEFENSE BEAT THE
RAMS TONIGHT.
THE BENGALS HANG AROUND FOR A
WHILE UNTIL THE CHIEFS PULL AWAY
FROM THE SECOND HALF AND WIN BY
A COUPLE OF TOUCHDOWNS.
CONNOR, THIS IS THE BOSS TALKING
RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS THE BOSS TALKING.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
DO YOU LIKE THIS OR DO YOU NOT?
>> THE BOSS BRINGING THE NFL
MATCHUP LEVEL ANALYSIS HERE.
LISTEN, I LIKE SOME OF THE TAKES
HERE.
I'M HIGH ON THE NINERS DEFENSE
IN THIS GAME.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
I -- THE ONLY PROBLEM I HAVE
WITH THIS ONE IS THE CHIEFS
PULLING AWAY BY A COUPLE
TOUCHDOWNS AT THE END.
THAT'S A LITTLE RICH FOR ME.
I THINK THE BENGALS CAN BACK
DOOR COVER THAT GAME.
I THINK THE BENGALS WITH HANG
AROUND.
BUT I LOVE WHAT THE BOSS IS
SAYING.
WE KNOW WHAT THIS NINERS GROUND
GAME CAN DO.
THE RAMS HAVE TO BE READY FOR
IT.
BUT THE RAM, AS TALENTED AS THEY
ARE, THOSE GUYS UP FRONT, YOU
GOT TO BE CAREFUL THOSE GUYS
DON'T OVERSHOOT AS PASS RUSHERS.
THEY WILL BE READY FOR THAT.
LOVE WHAT THE BOSS HAS TO SAY.
I THINK YOU DO, TOO.
I HAVE A FEELING YOU ARE ROLLING
WITH THE BOSS ON THIS ONE.
>> YEAH.
I JUST LIKE HOW THE BOSS LAYED
IT OUT FOR US, TOLD US WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AND JUST, YEAH,
I LIKE THE WAY THE BOSS LAYS IT
OUT STRAIGHT FOR US.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
COMMENTER.
WE HAVE S. ROSS 21.
SAYS RAMS WILL BLOW OUT SAN
FRANCISCO.
BENGALS WILL SQUEAK OUT BY A
FIELD GOAL.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS ONE,
CONNOR.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS ONE.
BUT TALK TO US.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO LET ME START WITH THE SECOND
POINT AND THEN THROW THE FIRST
POINT BACK TO YOU.
IF THE BENGALS ARE GOING TO WIN
THIS GAME, THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT WILL BE A NAIL BITING FIELD
GOAL.
THE BEELS AND CHIEFS, WE ALREADY
IT, RIGHT?
COUNTER PUNCH, COUNTER PUNCH,
HEY MAKER.
AND THEN YOU LOOK UP AND THE
BELL RINGS AND SOMEBODY HAS A
HIGHER TOTAL.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT
GAME.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE BENGALS,
THEY HAVE TO KEEP THROWING IN
THIS ONE.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP TRYING TO KEEP
UP WITH THE SHOOT-OUT THAT IT
IS.
AND THE ONLY WAY THEY WIN IS IF
THEY CAN CONTROL THE CLOCK AT
THE END AND KICK THAT FIELD GOAL
TO CLOSE IT OUT.
TAKE THE BALL OUT OF MAHOMES'
HANDS.
STEVE IS ON THE MONEY WITH THAT
MONEY.
THE FIRST ONE, GREG, RAMS WILL
BLOW OUT SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M NOT EXPECTING ANY BLOW-OUTS
FOR THE CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIP
GAMES.
I ALREADY SAID I LIKE THE NINERS
PLUS THREE AND A HALF.
I DON'T SEE THEM LOSING BY MORE
THAN A FIELD GOAL.
SPEAK TO THIS ONE, GREG.
BLOWN OUT?
WITH YOU IN ATTENDANCE?
>> NO, MAN.
THIS 49ERS TEAM, I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO GET BLOWN OUT.
THEY HAVE BEEN RESILIENT ALL
YEAR.
WE SAW WHAT THEY DID IN WEEK 18
AGAINST THIS SAME RAMS TEAM.
WHEN THEY WERE DOWN BIG AT
HALFTIME AND CAME BACK AND WON
THAT GAME.
WE SAW THE RESILIENCY LAST WEEK
AGAINST THOSE PACKERS DOWN SEVEN
AT HALFTIME.
CAME BACK AND WON THAT GAME
AGAINST THE MVP OF THIS SEASON.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SEE A
BLOW-OUT.
THAT'S NOT EVEN FANS SPEAKING,
BUT THAT'S JUST BEING A REALIST.
THIS 49ERS TEAM, THEY STARTED
OFF.
THEY WERE STRUGGLING AT FIRST.
THEY STRUGGLED OUT THE GATES.
THEY'RE IN THE NFC CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME.
SO THIS TEAM JUST HAVE A LOT OF
FIGHT.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF RESILIENCY
AND I CAN'T SEE THEM GETTING
BLOWN-OUT TODAY.
>> NO.
THAT'S A LOT.
A LOT TO GO WITH HERE.
SOMEBODY HAS TO TAKE HOME THE
HOODIE HERE, GREG.
I KNOW YOU LIKE TO SHOW LOVE TO
THE DOUBTERS A LOT.
ARE YOU GIVING IT TO THE DOUBTER
IN STEVE OR IS THE BOSS ANY
LEVEL ANALYSIS TAKING IT HOME?
>> WE'RE GOING TO ROCK WITH THE
BOSS.
WE GAVE US A REAL IN DEPTH
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT HE THINKS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN THIS WEEKEND.
SO WE'RE GOING TO ROCK WITH THE
BOSS AND HOOK HIM UP WITH THE
JERSEY OF HIS CHOICE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON, WHICH I KNOW
EVERYBODY IS HIGHLY
ANTICIPATING, ANXIOUSLY WAITING
FOR, WE GOT SOMETHING IN
SPECIAL, SOMETHING SPECIAL
PLANNED RIGHT NOW.
AS YOU KNOW, ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
PROPS ALL YEAR.
WE DID IT FOR EVERY GAME.
WE KEPT AN EYE ON IT FOR MOST OF
THE PLAYOFF GAMES.
OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT KINGS
SPICING THINGS UP JUST A LITTLE
BIT FOR US.
GREG, WHAT DO THEY HAVE FOR THIS
WEEKS NO SCORE FIRST DRIVE?
>> THE QUESTION IS THIS WEEKEND
WILL THERE -- WILL THE OPENING
OFFENSE SCORE IN THE FIRST DRIVE
OF THE RAMS/49ERS GAME?
DRAFT KINGS IS BOOSTING THOSE
ODDS TO PLUS 200, MY FRIEND.
>> I'LL JUST JUMP IN.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> I'LL JUMP IN.
IT IS A LOW SCORING -- IT IS A
LOW POINT TOTAL FOR A REASON,
CONNOR.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH NO.
I THINK THE RAMS WILL GET THE
BALL FIRST, AND I THINK THEY
WILL GET -- THEY ARE GOING TO
GET STOPPED.
49ERS GET THE BALL FIRST.
KYLE SHANAHAN'S FIRST 15.
HE LIKES TO DRAW THEM UP, BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING OFF TO
THE SLOW STARTS.
THEY GOT OFF TO A SLOW START.
>> I'M GOING WITH YOU.
I'M GOING WITH NO SCORE AS WELL.
I THINK THERE WILL BE A FEELING
OUT PROCESS IN THIS GAME.
BOTH TEAMS WILL BE CONTENT TO
TRY TO ESTABLISH THE RUN.
YOU MIGHT MY MOST HATED STRATEGY
OF PUT YOURSELF IN THIRD AND
LONG.
I DON'T THINK EITHER TEAM IS IN
A RUSH.
YOU KNOW, THEY'D LOVE TO COME
OUT OF THE GATE AND SCORE EARLY,
BUT I DON'T THINK THEY WILL TAKE
THE CHANCES TO DO SO.
NOT WITH JIMNY AND HONESTLY, NOT
WITH STAFFORD.
SO I'M ON IT.
I'M ON THE NO SCORE FIRST DRIVE
AS WELL.
WHAT DO THE COMMENTS THINK RIGHT
NOW?
ARE THEY GOING WITH NO POINTS OR
ARE THEY ROLLING WITH SOMEBODY
COMING OUT OF THE GATE AND
MAKING A BOLD PLAY?
>> SPACE ALIEN SAYS RAMS DO,
49ERS DO.
I GOT NY22GC SAYS NO, NO, NO.
FIRST DRIVE TD AND RAMS/SAN
FRANCISCO.
FIELD GOAL RAMS FIRST DRIVE.
OKAY.
I GUESS THEY ARE GOING WITH A
FIELD GOAL.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
I GOT A ANOTHER ONE.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING, BRO.
ROCKING ON THE NO SCORE FIRST
DRIVE.
THEY ARE RIDING WITH THE NO
SCORE FIRST DRIVE.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
>> AND SHOUT-OUT TO FRANK IN THE
COMMENTS WHO SAID SOMEBODY GET
THESE SPAMMING LOSERS OUT OF THE
COMMENTS.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO FRANK IN THERE.
GUYS, YOU DON'T HAVE TO SPAM US.
GREG IS READING IT ALL.
YOU WILL GET THE HOODIES.
IT'S TIME TO HAVE SOME FUN.
GREG, YOU GOT A JERSEY.
YOU GOT A HOODIE TO GIVE AWAY.
WE WILL CLOSE THIS THING OUT
DOWN THE ROAD WITH AIR PODS.
LET ME KNOW WHAT WE NEED.
THIS IS OUR FAVORITE TIME OF THE
SHOW.
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
LET US KNOW WHERE YOU ARE
ROCKING WITH ME.
LET US KNOW IF YOU ARE ROCKING
WITH MY BOY, CONNOR.
YEAH.
TYPE IT.
GET INTO IT.
GIVE US A TAKE.
GIVE US A BOLD BET AS WELL.
BUT, CONNOR, ARE YOU READY, MAN?
GE
>> I HAD TO SEND THIS IN BEFORE
I FOUND OUT WHO OUR SQUAD RIDE
WINNER WAS EVEN GOING TO BE
BECAUSE WE DO THAT ON THE SHOW.
I SEND IN THE BOLDEST BET WHEN
THINGS KICK OFF ON SATURDAY.
I WENT WITH Ja'MARR CHASE.
NOT TO SCORE ONCE, BUT TO SCORE
TWICE HERE, GREG.
PLUS 600.
HE HAS NOT SCORED IN A COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
BUT YOU NAILED IT TO SAY HE'S
BEEN KNOCKING ON THE DOOR.
THE CATCHES ARE THERE.
THE YARDS ARE THERE.
SO Ja'MARR CHASE PLUS 600 TO GET
IN THE END ZONE.
NOT ONCE.
NOT TWICE.
I KNOW YOU TEASED YOUR BOLDEST
BET AND KEPT THE PEOPLE HANGING
AROUND WAITING TO FIND OUT WHAT
IT'S GOING TO BE.
WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR CONFERENCE
CHAMPIONSHIP WEEKEND?
>> I'M IN L.A.
I'M IN L.A., CONNOR.
49ERS/RAMS.
I WILL BE IN ATTENDANCE.
SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
GAME.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE SAN
FRANCISCO 49ERS.
THEY HAVE BEATEN THIS RAMS TEAMS
SIX TIMES IN A ROW.
THEY HAVE BEATEN THIS RAMS TEAM
TWICE THIS SEASON.
BEATEN THE TEAM THREE TIMES IN
ONE SEASON IS A TOUGH, TOUGH
TASK.
BUT THE WAY THAT THE SAN
FRANCISCO 49ERS TEAM RUNS THE
BALL, THE WAY THE SAN FRANCISCO
49ERS TEAMS PLAYS DEFENSE AND
THE WAY THAT THIS SAN FRANCISCO
49ERS TEAM MATCHED UP AGAINST
THESE L.A. RAMS IN THE PAST TWO
PLUS SEASONS IS GIVING ME NO
OTHER REASON THAN TO BELIEVE
THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ERS IS
GOING TO COME DOWN TO SOFI
STADIUM.
IT IS GOING TO BE FULL OF RED.
THE STADIUM WILL BE FULL OF RED.
AND I WILL HAVE MY RED ON, TOO.
I WILL HAVE MY RED ON, TOO, AT
THE GAME, CONNOR.
THE HAT DON'T WANT ME TO BE
GREAT.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE GREAT.
IT WILL BE FULL RED.
AND THE NINERS WILL WALK OUT OF
THERE WITH A VICTORY.
SO TAKE THE ALTERNATE SPREAD.
DON'T TAKE THE MONEY LINE.
YOU CAN TAKE THE SAFE BET IN THE
SPREAD.
YOU CAN TAKE THAT, PARLAY, DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO.
BUT TAKE THE ALTERNATE SPREAD
RIGHT HERE.
IT IS PLUS/MINUS -- IT'S PLUS
175.
IT'S GOING TO BE A RED OUT IN
SOFI TODAY, CONNOR.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE GAME, MAN.
>> GREG IS READY TO GO.
HE'S NOT TAKING NINERS PLUS
POINTS.
HE'S NOT TAKING NINERS MONEY
LINE.
HE'S GOING WITH THE SMART
STRATEGY, THAT THEY WILL WIN BY
A FIELD GOAL JUST IN CASE THAT
GOES INTO OVER TIME, GREG.
THAT'S THE WAY.
THAT'S THE WAY TO DO IT.
>> I KNOW YOU ARE EXCITED.
BUT I STILL NEED YOU TO GET AWAY
THIS JERSEY BEFORE YOU HEAD TO
THE GAME.
SO WE HAVE TO GET IN THE HANDY
CANADY.
THE HAT STAYS ON.
GREG IS ROLLING WITH THE MINORS.
WE WANT TO KNOW, GUYS, WHICH
BOLDEST BETS ARE YOU ROCKING
WITH.
LET GREG KNOW RIGHT NOW.
ARE YOU GOING WITH THE NINERS?
Ja'MARR CHASE?
YOU CAN GO WITH EITHER OF THEM,
SEPARATE GAMES.
DOESN'T MATTER.
>> I GOT TO TAKE THE HAT OFF
BECAUSE I HAVE TO THINK RIGHT
HERE ABOUT WHO I AM TRYING TO
HOOK UP WITH THIS HOODIE AND
ALSO GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY AIR PODS, TOO.
OH, MY GOSH.
HERE WE GO.
I'M ROCKING WITH CONNOR, BEATING
A TEAM THREE TIMES IN A SEASON
IS SO HARD TO SEE HAPPEN.
HONESTLY, I AGREE.
THEREFORE, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE BECAUSE I AGREE
BUT I THINK IT IS THE PLAYOFFS
BUT THINGS HAPPEN IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
WE ALSO GOT CONNOR HAS GOT A
GREAT TAKE.
IT JUST WENT AWAY.
THE COMMENTS JUST WENT AWAY.
YOU GUYS COULD SEE IT ON YOUR
SCREEN.
>> LYING.
>> I MENTIONED HIS NAME.
PRODUCERS, PLEASE REMEMBER HIS
NAME.
GIVE HIM A HOODIE.
LET'S MOVE ON.
I GOT LOGAN WHO SAYS MAHOMES
OVER 400 PASSING YARDS AND THREE
TDs.
FIRE.
ROCKING WITH GREG.
FADE CONNOR.
NO, WE'RE NOT FADING.
THAT RIGHT THERE IS GIVING A
HOODIE.
NOT A HOODTY, A JERSEY, I'M
SORRY.
CONNOR, BROTHER, I'M READY TO
GET TO THIS GAME.
I'M READY TO GO WATCH THIS
MATCHUP LATER TODAY.
ACTUALLY, THE FIRST MATCHUP IS
MINUTES AWAY.
AND I'M READY.
I'M READY TO TURN ON THIS TV AND
GET IT STARTED, MAN.
>> YEAH, IT IS ABOUT THAT TIME
WE GET ON UP OUT OF HERE.
BUT BEFORE WE DO, THE GOOD VIBES
ROLL ON BECAUSE WE GOT AIR POD
PROS TO GIVE AWAY.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING VERY
SIMPLE.
WE WANT TO KNOW THE BEST BETS TO
WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
CHAMPIONSHIP ODDS RIGHT NOW AS
IT STANDS HEADING INTO THE
CONFERENCE CHAMPIONSHIP GAMES.
THE CHIEFS PLUS 125.
RAMS PLUS 200.
NINERS SITTING THERE A LITTLE
BIT OF A GAP AT PLUS 450.
AND THEN THE BENGALS LOOKING WAY
DOWN THE BOARD AT PLUS 800.
SO IF YOU WANT TO GET IN ON
THESE AIR POD PROS, GREG, LET
THEM KNOW WHAT THEY GOT TO DO
RIGHT NOW.
>> I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME YOUR LOCKS
TO WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND A LITTLE.
AND IF YOUR COMMENT MATCHES THE
TEAM CHOSEN BY THE WILL, YOU,
YES YOU, COULD WIN A PAIR OF AIR
POD PROS.
I'M JEALOUS.
I'M ABOUT THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
HOPEFULLY MY COMMENT GETS
CHOSEN.
>> AND YOU GOT TO BE RIGHT.
NOW, THE WHEEL IS GOING TO BE
RAN
RANDOM.
I'M GOING TO THROW MY PICK IN
HERE.
I'M PLAYING THE ODDS.
YOU KNOW, IN AUGUST WHEN GREG
AND I WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT
GUESTS DID OUR SHOW, I WAS
ROLLING WITH THE RAMS AS ONE OF
MY FUTURES PICK.
BUT AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW, IF I
WAS PLAYING THIS BOARD, I LIKE
THE NINERS.
I LIKE THE NINERS OVER THERE AT
PLUS 400, PLUS 450, RIGHT AROUND
THERE.
I THINK THAT'S THE ODDS TO PLAY.
SURE THE CHIEFS ARE THE EASY,
CHALKY PICK.
NOT THAT GREAT OF ODDS.
I LIKE THE NINERS.
GREG, I KNOW YOU DO, TOO.
I DON'T HAVE TO ASK.
BUT I WILL ANYWAY BEFORE WE GET
THIS WHEEL GOING.
>> CONNOR, I KNOW YOU REMEMBER.
WE HAD --
>> RIGHT.
>> WE WERE GOING THROUGH THIS
BEFORE THE SEASON, BEFORE THE
SEASON, BROTHER.
EVERYBODY WAS GOING THROUGH
THEIR SUPER BOWL PICKS.
AND I SAID THE 49ERS AND
EVERYBODY STARTED LAUGHING AT ME
TALKING ABOUT WE DON'T GOT NO
QUARTERBACK, THIS AND THAT.
BUT LOOK AT US NOW.
LOCK AT US NOW.
>> IT'S COME DOWN TO THIS.
YOU GUYS KNOW I GOT A FUTURE
TICKET.
I GOT THEM TO WIN THE NFC.
ALSO GOT A TICKET ON THE SUPER
BOWL.
I'M NOT GOING WITH THE NINERS,
MAN.
I THINK THEY HAVE THE IDENTITY.
THEY HAVE -- THEY HAVE THE
IDENTITY AS A TEAM OF WHAT IT
TAKES TO WIN THE SUPER BOWL, RUN
THE FOOTBALL, PLAY DEFENSE.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE BOYS FROM
SAN FRANCISCO, CONNOR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET IT GOING.
LET'S GET THE WHEEL SPINNING.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL NOW.
IF THE WHEEL LANDS ON YOUR TEAM
THAT YOU PINCKED IN THE COMMENT,
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO WIN THE AIR
POD PROS.
LET'S WASTE NO TIME.
25% CHANCE IT LANDS ON YOUR TEAM
IN THIS AND THEN GREG IS GOING
TO TAKE IT AWAY AND GIVE OUT THE
AIR PODS.
AND WE GOT THE RAMS.
THE RAMS.
THE WHEEL IS GOING WITH.
THE LAST TIME WE DID THIS, THEY
DID NOT GO WITH THE RAMS.
THIS IS A -- THE WHEEL IS FADING
YOU, GREG.
THE WHEEL IS FADING YOU.
>> HEY.
THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY FINE.
THE WHEEL IS FADING ME.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT I WANT TO SEE.
OKAY.
I GOT -- OKAY, HERE WE GO.
JAY FRY 14 SAYS SORRY, GREG.
THERE HE IS.
SORRY, GREG, NOT THIS TIME WITH
THE RAMS LAUGHING.
THERE IT IS.
GUESS WHAT?
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH SOME
AIR PODS, BROTHER.
IT IS LOVE ON THIS SIDE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH AIR
PODS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
SHOUT-OUT TO THE RAMS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WIN TODAY.
>> THAT'S A WRAP.
GREG IS TELLING YOU YOUR TEAM IS
GOING TO LOSE, BUT AS A
CONSOLATION, YOU GET AIR POD
PROS.
PRETTY SWEET DEAL.
FOR THOSE WINNERS, DON'T WORRY,
BR BETTING WILL DM YOU IF GREG
SHOUTED YOU OUT FOR A HOODIE, A
JERSEY, THE AIR PODS.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW.
WE HAVE GIVEN OUT PRIZES NONSHOP
IN THIS SHOW.
IT WILL NOT STOP THERE.
WE WILL BE BACK FOR SUPER BOWL
SUNDAY, THE SAME 1:00 A.M.
EAST
EASTERN.
SHOUT-OUT TO OUR LOCK LEGENDS.
MAKE SURE TO GET ON DRAFT KINGS.
IF YOU ARE FIRST TIME $5 TO WIN
$280.
THROW A MONEY LINE BET.
GET THE BONUS BET MONEY.
IT'S FREE MONEY.
IF YOU ARE IN LOUISIANA, BET ON
JOE BURROW TO COMPLETE A PASS.
IT'S FREE MONEY.
IT'S GOT TO BE.
JOE BURROW HAS TO COMPLETE A
PASS AND DON'T FORGET ABOUT THE
NO SCORE FIRST DRIVE.
BOOSTED TO PLUS 200.
AND ALSO DON'T FORGET Ja'MARR
CHASE BOOSTED TO PLUS 125.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO ON THIS SHOW.
WE'RE MAKING IT EASIER TO BET.
PLEASE SEND US YOUR REACTION
VIDEOS AND DROP YOUR REAL-TIME
TAKES ON THE BR BETTING APP.
JOIN US SUPER BOWL SUNDAY, TWO
WEEKS 11:00 A.M. EASTERN TIME.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS.
HE'S GREG IVORY.
SEE YOU IN TWO WEEKS.